there is no other Arc in one piece that
has been anticipated by fans as hard and
as long as elath the country with these
strongest Warriors in the world home of
the notorious Giants and territory of
the emperor Shanks and so today I want
to talk about everything that could and
should happen in this long awaited Arc
starting from the things that are
absolutely 100% going to happen like Uso
bleeding an army of Mighty Giants or
Luffy finally reuniting with Shanks and
then slowly moving to the most insane
elb theories out there like how God NL
is going to return to attack the land of
giants as well but let's start at the
beginning because since Dr Vega Punk has
given us the Intel that Jaguar dul is
alive and well and hiding the remains of
the library of Ohara on elb it's now
basically guaranteed that the straw
Hat's next destination is going to be
the island of giants not even mentioning
this note from Oda at the jump Festa
that all but guarantees us that we're
getting some real giant-sized action in
one piece in 2024 in fact during the
ekad island arc Oda treated fans to a
detour to check on what all of the other
yonko besides Luffy are currently up to
and as it turns out most of them have
basically been spending their downtime
absolutely obliterating Luffy Supernova
allies kid and law in fact when eustus
kid threatened the weakling pirates that
call chanks their friend the superior
redard pirate wiped out the master of
magnetism who took down big mom with
just a single slash of his sword and our
old friends from little Garden Way Back
Dory and broggy here also wiped out kids
ship with their signature technique Haku
sovereignty and so thanks to this
cutaway to Shanks and the giant Pirates
we do know that Luffy's touchdown in
Elba would mean a reunion with some old
friends Uso for one is sure going to be
excited to reunite with his Heroes Dory
and broggy who the crew hasn't seen
since little Garden in the alabaster
Saga however on top of that Usopp might
also get to see his other giant comrades
like Almo and Kashi who were guards at
an Lobby until Uso revealed that the
government had tricked them into their
service and because we're meeting all of
these elev Giants once again maybe even
haidu Jin will show up along with the
rest of the grand Fleet depending on
what kind of mortal threat emerges on
the island of elb and of course I'll be
talking about who the Big Bad Evil of
elb might actually be in just a bit but
of course this reunion with the Giants
is going to be nothing compared to the
reunion that we've all been waiting for
since chapter 1 of the series series
because that's right Luffy will finally
reunite with Shanks once again now that
he's become a powerful pirate a yonko in
the very same class as his mentor and
how will that play out well Luffy is
sure to shed tears just like he did when
he met with Sao again however we don't
think that the tears will come right
away instead I think before Shanks even
gets to mutter much at all he'll
probably get a gum gum punch right to
the face with Luffy finally proving that
his punches are as strong as pistol but
Jokes Aside here there's actually no
real guarantee that the reunion of these
two will be totally friendly because at
the end of wano Shanks declared that
it's finally time for him and his crew
to seek out the one piece as well and
we're actually not sure how many road
poneglyphs Shanks actually has already
claimed but Luffy and the straw hats
have three of them and it's very
unlikely that Shanks has the ones from
zo or from wano since those were very
well hidden by their respective people
and only shared them with the straw hats
after they had saved their countries so
does does this mean that just how kid
got wrecked Luffy will also find himself
at the end of shank's Sword well Shanks
finally reveal his true colors in order
to get his hands on the poneglyphs well
he probably doesn't need to since he
likely retrieved all of the poneglyph
etchings from what little remains of
kid's crew at this point I mean after
all they did offer them to him in order
to try and save themselves just before
their ship was then demolished by Dorian
broy and speaking of which we're going
to have to find out exactly what became
of used as kits I mean for one Luffy
will definitely be surprised to see that
his rival who helped take out big mom
and kaido has been decimated by his old
Mentor now to be fair we of course know
how bad Oda is at actually killing off
characters so is kid actually dead here
or will he show back up on elb with even
more metal body parts enough that he
could be straight up mistaken for a
Frankie creation at this point will he
finally give up on trying to defeat
chins or will he crawl his way back onto
elb only to give us a shocked annal
phase when he sees Luffy and Shanks ping
around eating giant husks of meat
together in fact I think that might only
be one of many ANL phes that we'll get
in this Arc but more on that in just a
moment first off Shanks would make for a
hell of a Twist villain I mean just
imagine Luffy's mentor and hero who
inspired him to become a pirate from the
very beginning ending up being the
ultimate obstacle preventing him from
his dream that would just be devastating
but as popular as the evil shank's
theory is I honestly just don't see it
he has an entire fleet of weak Pirates
who he defends even though they're not
strong enough to make it in the New
World by themselves he stopped the war
at Marine for to prevent further
Bloodshed he inspires young Pirates like
Luffy and then the young Giant on elb to
become Pirates and of course he did help
Luffy on wano as well so he just doesn't
seem that evil as mysterious as he
admittedly is in fact maybe we'll even
get an answer to some of the Mysteries
that suround Shanks in this Arc like is
he actually a Celestial Dragon as it
does seem like why was he found in a
treasure chest on God Valley only Mak
sense that we get more answers to all
these questions and more in this Shanks
centered Arc however as far as we know
Shanks doesn't actually seem to have a
way to read the poneglyphs so maybe
there's another way besides Force to get
something he needs and so instead of
going all out in a bloody battle against
the straw hats maybe we'll just get a
return of the good old Dave backfire
fight after all long ring Long Island is
one of the few one piece arcs that
doesn't appear to have much
foreshadowing or connections to any of
the other Arc so far which makes many
one piece fans speculate that the Davey
back fight will play some important role
at some point in the story and so I mean
just imagine a foot race between Sanji
and luyu who is supposed to be the
fastest character in the series we have
a musical matchup between Soul King
Brooke and another rockar rockar even
though Bonk punch is their actual
musician and the ultimate game of darts
between Father and Son when Uso finally
gets to show his father yaso just how
much he has grown as a sniper oh and
yeah actually speaking of Usopp if hul
cake Island gave us the year of Sanji
and wano gave Zoro a ton of focus then
welcome to the year of usub I think
because no character has dreamed of
visiting elb more than Uso he's been the
one to make friends with all all of the
Giants that the crew has met along their
Journey well except hydogen but that's
only because hydogen just straight up
started worshiping Usopp as a God and so
I think it's just fitting that on the
island of Brave and powerful warriors
usub will also finally be able to
reunite with his father yasa however
this is sure to be the arc that usab
finally lives out his dream of becoming
a brave Warrior of the SE most one piece
fans including you I assume know that
Uso's lies have had a tendency in the
story to actually come true which also
means that in this Arc it's very likely
that usub will lead an army of 8,000 men
and not just any old men I mean an army
of actual Giants who exactly will this
Army be fighting you ask well only time
will tell but we do have some ideas but
on top of that usub is also due for a
massive power up and while I can
definitely see him using bega Punk Tech
to get the most technologically advanced
slingshot of all time elb will be the
actual Arc that Usopp Taps into into his
new hockey ability for one he's already
had one of the greatest observation
hockey feeds in the series when he took
out sugar and Dr Rosa from miles away
but this might just be the arc when he
Taps into conqueror's hockey as well yes
because after all someone fit to lead an
entire Army of 8,000 Giants does seem
like a quite decent candidate to have
the color of the Supreme King as much as
it might be weird to think about right
now and actually speaking of conquer
hockey users we might just get the
return of a former yonko as well big mom
I'll buy with uh way more lava scars in
that case I mean I just mentioned with
kid how bad Oda is actually with killing
off characters so will big mom crawl her
way back out of the lava beneath wano to
seek revenge against the straw hats and
their allies once again but even if big
mom is actually dead she'll be sure to
affect the elb arc one way or another
because her flashback with Mother
caramel is the first time that we
actually got to see elbaff in the manga
and honestly it also felt like certain
plot threats in hul KCK Island were
unresolved with big mom seeking to Ally
with the Giants and add elb to her
forces enabling her to finally claim the
one piece we're also certain to meet
Loki the prince of the Giants who was
arranged to marry big mom's daughter
Lola and I mean maybe while we're ated
we'll even get to see Lola again as well
as her twin sister chiffon along with
cabone beige and pounce basically it'll
be a hul cake Island reunion and while
we're at it if Blackbeard shows up in
this Arc as well as a villain it would
make sense for the remnants of the big
mom Pirates to face him down since he's
the one who kidnapped pudding and so
katakuri and Luffy could actually join
forces to maybe make the stretchiest
team in all of manga and while I'm
talking about big mom will the Giants
kind of recognize Zeus and freak out
once Nami shows up on the island as well
I mean given their intense history with
Mother caramel and big mom a lot of them
are sure to recognize the concept of
homies and some of them might even
recognize Zeus specifically and insane
transition incoming Zeus isn't the only
lightning user of course who we're bound
to see on elb because if there's a Loki
then we do need a Thor and as it happens
El Thor is a signature attack of the one
and only Gods NL now for anyone who's
actually been skipping their cover
stories first of all you're missing out
insanely because one cover story has
confirmed that enl survived skypia and
actually ended up flying his ark Maxim
all the way to the fairy worth in other
words the moon so yeah that's right it's
time for moon piece on the moon he found
the remnants of an advanced civilization
and used his electricity to awaken a
literal robot army of automatons oh and
also he met actual space pirates like
there's no way that all of that doesn't
become relevant in the story at some
point and with the final Saga well
underway at this point we're kind of
running out of time to bring enel back
into the fold so it's only a matter of
time before this wannabe God shows back
up in fact will'll probably learn a lot
more about many of the sky Islanders in
general in elb for example The Mad Monk
arouge Is the last Supernova that has
yet to play an actual role in one of the
story arcs and it just so happens that
arou is from burka the same sky island
that anel is from and destroyed before
moving onto skypia with his priests in
fact it's very much possible that urou
even used to be one of enel's priests
before they parted waste and elb will
very likely treat us to a lot more more
lore about the sky islands in general
because when the straw heads went to
skypia the sky Islanders were shocked
that they'd actually used the knockup
stream to arrive there since it's an
extremely dangerous route to take and so
they actually referenced that the more
common and normal way to travel to
skypia is by taking something called the
high West Road and so could this path be
in the new world on elav and maybe even
be connected to the treasure tree atom
as you know during big mom's flashback
we see a giant black mass Rising complet
completely perpendicular to the land in
fact it's so big that we only get a
sliver of its total size from that panel
however just based on this most fans
speculate that this is actually the
legendary treasure tree atom the tree
known for having the strongest wood in
the world which coincidentally the
Thousand Sunny is made out of as well
and so could climbing this tree be the
secret to reaching other Sky Islands
after all the giant Warriors of elff are
based on Norse mythology which featur
the world Tre yrail which stretches all
the way up to Asgard the realm of the
Gods in the sky and of course if the
moon in some way or form does become
relevant and the straw heads do need to
learn more about the ancient
civilizations of the one piece World in
elb they might need to go even higher
than just the sky islands luckily as it
happens they have now befriended the
greatest scientist in the one piece
world and if anyone is capable of
actually creating space travel again it
is going to be Dr vapun but of course
the moon is just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the wild lore reveals
that oda's probably going to give us an
albath for one on ekad island we learned
that Robin's favorite giant Jaguar dool
is still alive and well hiding on elb
and that means that it's extremely
likely that he's uncovered the secrets
that the scholars of Ohara learned as
well in fact we might finally get to
hear the words that Professor Clover was
killed for threatening to reveal the
name of the ancient Kingdom itself but
at the very least we'll definitely learn
the location of the final poneglyph and
who could be guarding it if it is not on
elbaf itself with Shanks in fact jagard
dool is one of the contenders to be
revealed as the man with the burn scars
since he survived the burning of Ohara
however since the man with the burn
scars is supposed to be hiding on an all
black ship surrounded by whirlpools Saul
doesn't quite fit the description
however elb will likely give us a clue
as to where this mysterious figure can
be found and speaking of the atom tree
we you might finally learn more about
the treasure tree atom and its counts
aart the sunlight tree Eve which grows
around marijua and uh what does grow on
trees yeah fruits like devil fruit so
well we already got a lot of new
information about devil fruits on egad
island we might learn even more of their
Origins and secrets on albath and along
with the Norse mythology that's inspired
characters like Shanks Loki and the
other Giants who all take after Vikings
maybe we learn even more because all the
way back in little garden when Dory and
bragi used their Haku sovereignty
technique to defeat the island eater
fish they do mention that the only thing
that their attacks can Pierce is the
serpent soaked in Blood and as it
happens Norse mythology features a
creature called the jormun Gand the
giant snake that wraps around the entire
world so hm what's something that wraps
around all the way the one piece world
and is also red the color of something
soaked in blood but that's right the red
line itself so maybe we'll even get to
learn the history of this expansive
geological structure along with another
winged race of people who live there
which are the lunarians once again the
gods and who knows maybe we'll even see
an apocalyptic war on the level of the
Norse smth of Ragnarok well we've
already seen weapons with apocalyptical
powers in the series the ancient weapons
and the three islands that have had the
most buildup in the entire series were
Fishman Island wano and Elba Fishman
Island which was first mentioned during
arlong Park ended up being the hiding
place of Poseidon AKA princess
shirahoshi wano which was first
mentioned in Thrilla bark is the hiding
place of the battleship pluton so will
albath which was first referenced all
the way back on little garden be the
place where we actually see Uranus in
action as well actually since it's
possible that Uranus is the weapon that
was used by emu to destroy the lulua
kingdom we may have already seen it but
elff could be the place where the world
government tries to use it against the
straw heads themselves if it's not there
and of course that's not the only
possibility because maybe the real
Uranus is whatever hatched from The
Giant Egg on the back of Roger ship the
Oro Jackson but most important of all
though is that there's probably going to
be more lore about the sun got NAA
thanks to Mother caramel during big
mom's flashback we already know that the
Giants of elb worship a Sun God as well
and that means that elb is the perfect
place to learn more about the original
sod Nika and the original Joy boy and
their actions during the void Century in
fact as we know emo is also guarding a
giant Straw Hat within Pangia castle and
it's likely that the original Joy boy
might even have been a giant or at least
a member of the bucka tribe like
bartholomy Kuma and the person who's
inherited his will has somehow retained
the same sense of fashion but what
better way to learn about this ancient
giant than from the Giants of today but
of course even more than just l piece
what fans are really craving including
me from elb is non-stop giant sized
action you want to see battle ax as the
size of buildings flying around and
super sized conquer hockey clashes so
who will be the ultimate villain of the
Alba Arc will another goo or even emu
descent on the island after Saturn gets
possibly stomped on ekad Islands I mean
that would be a great reason for Uranus
to show up as well as a good reason for
the straw hats to call on the help of
the grand Fleet after all the world
government has been trying to use
science to recreate Giants for ages and
maybe this time they'll come straight to
the source will the god Knights maybe
even leap into action resulting in
shank's having a reencounter with his
past when his probably father figle and
Garling also sets foot on albath what if
Prince Loki is very much unlike the rest
of the kindly Giants that we've met so
far and a lot more like his tricks the
namesake from North mythology maybe the
straw hats will actually find themselves
at odds with the giant royalty or
perhaps it will be an even greater twist
where someone who we assumed is a friend
is actually an antagonist and the evil
Shanks Theory will actually come true
after all or maybe we'll even get a
completely anticlimactic enal rematch
with him leading a giant robot army
against the land of giants but of course
more than any of these there is one
villain more likely than any other for
elb Blackbeard one Shanks has been a
rival of Blackbeard throughout the
entire series teach gave him a signature
scar across his eyes and Shanks took the
time to warn Whitebeard of the threat
that the wielder of the darkness fruit
possessed at Marine Ford Blackbeard
stated that it wasn't time for his crew
to face Shanks yet which implies that
the two will fight before the end of the
series and so Blackbeard could roll up
to elb in search of the remaining
poneglyph either to steal whichever one
Shanks might have or to gain Clues from
Jaguar daa after all Oda did state that
his primary hobby is archaeology so he
would love to get his hands on the
remains of O'Hara's library and of
course as he approached he would lay
waste to the weakling Crews that are
allied with Shanks succeeding where kid
failed he would probably have an epic
matchup with Shanks making for one of
the greatest duels in one piece history
Shanks the greatest hockey master in all
of One Piece versus Blackbeard the only
character who somehow wields multiple
devil fruits and who knows maybe we'll
even get the reveal of Blackbeard's long
rumored third devil fruit as well which
many fans think to be a curus or Kraken
or some other mythical Zone to go along
with his loia and paramia and of course
the worst and most likely outcome of
this fight is that Shanks would actually
lose before Luffy is able to arrive
imagine the Heartbreak that every one
piece fan would feel if Luffy was
finally able to reunite with Shanks and
return the straw hat to him only for
Shanks to give dying words of how proud
he is of Luffy and leaving the one piece
and the title of king of pirates in the
hand hands of the Next Generation I'll
be real even though it's likely I
personally don't want this to happen at
all because Shanks dying at the hands of
a coward like Blackbeard would honestly
be kind of criminal however the
resulting rage that Luffy would fly into
in facing down Blackbeard who was now
responsible for the deaths of the two
most important people in his life would
be the most intense scene in the entire
Series so far and on top of everything
that we already mentioned alev is also
sure to deliver one of the craziest arcs
in one piece in general by finally
letting us know more about the culture
of the giant race and of course there
are actually still many people in one
piece that we still need to learn more
about like the lunarians and the sky
Islanders and so here's to hoping that
we will get more answers about all of
these in Alf as well but for now you can
get a reminder on everything that we
know about every race in all of One
Piece by checking out this video right
here Shanks for watching and I will see
you in the next one